شريحه زحريه من صنع ماسك ترجع البصر
لفاقديه وعلماء ومختصين محتجين ورئيسه
وزراء فنلندا ونيوزيلندا تردا بقوه على
سؤال تمييزي ضدهما ومن كانوا الاكثر
استماعا على سبوتفايف في 20 22 الاجابه
اخت تفاعلكم
[موسيقى]
تويتر والازمه اللي شعللها مع ابل الايام
الماضيه واللي رجع على فكره وهدف فيها
شويه وكشف انه التقى رئيس ابل وحلوا سواء
سوء التفاهم اللي كان صاير بينهم وزار
كمان مقر ابل ماسك يبدو كمان مو مكتفي
بالقلق اللي صاير سياسيين جوا امريكا وحتى
في مختلف دول العالم بسبب ابتلاكه تويتر
كانه كل هذا موقفه جالي اليوم انه يطلع
بشيء جديد يتصدر في العناوين شريحه
له ماسك متخصصه في علوم الاعصاب وشرائح
المخ اول مره يتكلم عنها ماسك وعلى فكره
وانتم محاته
واللي ممكن تعمله فوق ولكن الجديد هو
الاشياء اللي كشفها امس في مناسبه خاصه
بالشركه كانوا عازمين عليها ناس محدده طيب
قبل ما يقول لكم ايش اعلن ماسك خليني اشرح
لكم شويه عن طيب الشركه هذه اساسها ماسك
في 2016 وهدفها زراعه وصلت دماغيه لاسلكيه
بين الدماغ واجهزه كمبيوتر وعن طريق
تكنولوجيا معينه انهم يعالجوا حالات
مستعصيه وفي طموحاتهم علاج الزهايمر الخره
في اصابات الحبل الشوكي فقدان الذاكره
والسمع والبصر والارق والغيره والشركه
اصدرت شريحه باسمها
وبتجربها على حيوانات ومن سنتين عرضتنا
تجربتها على خنزير وعلى قرد كمان الجديد
اللي اعلنه في ايفنت امسك انه خلق الشركه
قدمت معظم الاوراق المطلوبه لهيئه الغذاء
والدواء الامريكيه للحصول على الموافقات
لبدء التجارب على البشر وقال انه خلال سته
اشهر التجارب على البشر المفروض انها تبدا
والشريحه مثلا شرح مره من زمان
يعني بتنزرع في الجمجمه عن طريق ازاله
الجزء منها وزراء الشريحه مكانها فكره انه
تجارب البشر تبدا كمان سته اشهر مو مفاجاه
الوحيده في كلام ماسك في المفاجاه اكثر
كمان عن كلامه عن التطبيقات العمليه اللي
راح تبدا بها التجارب على البشره
ابحار
اناني
المعصوص
ستيفن هوكينج
هما مساعده المصابين باعاقات الحركه على
التواصل واستعاده البصر للمكفوفين وخلينا
نقول انه هذه الاخيره تحديدا مفاجاه للكل
وتحديد اننا الاطباء والعلماء المتخصصين
في هذا المجال يعني البصره فقدان
واستعادته وعلاجه هذا مجال العلماء
بيدرسوه من مئات السنين وبيحاولوا انهم
يحلوا فبعول بعد سنوات من البحث الان جاء
مسك وهو اللي هيحل هذا الموضوع واصلا كيف
ممكن هذا الشيء خلونا نتكلم اكثر ونفهم من
ضيفنا واللي هذا المجال واختصاص وينضم
الينا استشاري طب وجراحه العيون دكتور
محمد جندي اهلا فيك دكتور محمد هل نقدر
نقول انه فعلا ماسك ممكن يحقق هذا النوع
من يعني معجزه هي يعني او خلينا نقول
اختراق كبير
اهلا وسهلا ومساكم الله بالخير
اول شيء اتمنى اتمنى ان يكون كلام صحيح
ان شاء الله كان بالنسبه للعين كانت
بالنسبه للامراض العصبيه او اي مرض بالجسم
فبصراحه كده حيحلنا مشاكل العالم الحمد
لله وهذا الشيء نحن كلنا نبغاه الحمد لله
الامراض دي تشفى منها
لكن خلينا نفكر بمنطقه بسيطه
يمنع الموت طيب كلام جميل لكن خلينا نفكر
الموت والوفاء لها سبب جدا جدا
اي شيء ممكن يحصل يعمل لنا وفاء فهل هذا
الشيء اللي انت جبته
على الوفاه لكل الاسباب هذه بصراحه يعني
هيكون اول شيء غير يعني لو تطبق هذا
الكلام على العين اسباب العمى على العين
جدا كثيره بتتكلم عن مثلا قرنيه العين
بتتكلم عن عصب العين شبكيه العين بعدين
العصب اللي ياخذ الصوره من العين الى
الدماغ وبعدين الدماغ اللي راح يترجم
الصوره هذه عشان انت تشوفها فهو بيتكلم عن
اي عمو بالضبط فيها لانه انواع العمل فيها
جدا جدا مختلفه يعني ههه
هذا الكلام يقدر يخلينا نقول انه همم لسه
هم بيشتغلوا على تطوير الموضوع ولا انه
كلامهم لا هو لامي واقرب لانه الترويج
الزائر
اممم التالوج الثالث ما توقع يعني شخصيه
زي اول ماسكه كده ما شاء الله بيعمل اشياء
جدا كبيره المفروض هو بيقول حاجه يعني حتى
لو انها كان حاجه في المستقبل البعيد او
القريب ان شاء الله يا رب يا رب انها تكون
صحيحه يعني وان تكون على قدر الشيء هذا
يعني نحن بنلعب على مصداق
اكيد لكن حكايه انه مثلا في شريحه مو احنا
ممكن نزرعها في العين تخلي الشخص مثلا
يشوفن يتحسن النظر خلينا نقول هذا الشيء
ترى موجود بين فتره لكن طعمهم طبق على
البشر بالشكل الكبير انه مثلا في امراض
معينه اللي مثلا تصيب الشبكيه يكون في
ثالث الشبكه فالشخص الواحد مثلا زي
الشريحه في الشبكيه للعام بعد كده النظر
عند الشخص راح يتحسن بدرجه جدا بسيطه
نتكلم عن مثلا 5% 10% الشيء خلينا نقول
انه ما كان يشوف لكن صار يشوف اضاءه عشان
يشوف حركه بسيطه عن هذه النظر اقدر اخليه
يمارس حياته يروح ويجيء زي ما بيقول انه
يجي عندي
جدا وهو بيتكلم حتى انه بيقول انه الناس
اللي مولودين حتى مكفوفين طيب خلينا نقول
لك حاجه بس اذكرها او في ال- او البيانات
اللي طلعت عن التجارب اللي عملوها واحنا
من الاشياء اللي قالوها انه همم القرود
اللي تعرضوا له هذه الشريحه
تعالوا من تعب ومرض وما الى ذلك طيب الان
اذا هم اتعبوا من هذا الشيء هل هذا الشيء
برده يقدر يخلي الاف دي اي او اداره
الغذاء والدواء الامريكيه توافق على انه
يتم تجربه الموضوع على الانسان
وحقيقه جابت نتيجه لهم ايش نوع المرض اللي
كان عندهم وهم بالشريحه هذه عالج المرض
هذا كل الموضوع هيكون يعني واضح للكل يعني
حتى هتكون مصداقيه عنده اعلى همم لكن ما
نقدر زي ما قلنا يعني الموضوع بشكل كبير
يسعدك
احنا في التجربه خلى انه مثلا قرد يعزف
وما الى ذلك بس انه كانت النتيجه تعب
فايش معايير الاف دي ايه عشان يقبلوا انه
ننتقل لمرحله البشر
طبعا اول شيء انه يثبته انه هذا الشيء ما
هو مضر ما هو مضر لا للقرده والحكم مضر
للانسان هذا مرحله اولى والمرحله الثانيه
يثبت انه هذا الشيخ حقيقي مفيد كان
للحيوانات يعني امن ومفيد وبعد كده ممكن
يدخل مرحله تطبيق وعلى البشر في اجزاء
معينه في حالات معينه طبعا تحت اشراف
يعني بتقنيه لو تحققت حتى تكون رائعه جدا
فان شاء الله انها تتحقق وبنشكرك على هذه
التوزيعات كان معنا استشاري طب هو جراحه
العيون دكتور محمد جوجل شكرا لك
رئيسه وزراء فنلندا بتقوم بزياره الى
نيوزيلندا هي الاولى لرئيس وزراء فرندي
الى نيوزيلندا و خلال الزياره التقطت طبعا
بنظيرتها نيوزلنديه
وبعد اللقاء عقد كمان مؤتمر صحفي مشترك
يعني كلها ترى الي بحكي لكم عنها امور
طبيعيه
جدا
خلال المؤتمر الصحفي في واحد صحفي سال
سؤال ما عجب الرئيس تان ارد عليه على
السريع وللصراحه السؤال يعني ما عجبنا حتى
احنا كمان
يوتيوب
[موسيقى]
حول العالم لانه
بيحمل كثير من التمييز ضد المراه يعني
كانه بيقول لهم انتم مجتمعين بس لانكم
ستات زي بعض واعماركم قريبه من بعض لانهم
عمرها 37
وجسمنا 42 يعني كانهم يعني انه صحتين
وتوعدوا على عشاء وبصراحه شكرا رئيستين
الحكومه انه يرد عليه ويشوفوا غليلنا وما
خلوا الموضوع يعدي وكانها جمله عاديه يعني
علاج
الغمراتهم يبقى سؤال انه الامتحان عالي يا
جماعه من التمييزات هذا هل المراه خلاص
محكوم حياتها كلها انها تفضل تعاني من
التمييز هذا والنظره هذه يعني حتى رئيسات
حكومات وصلوا لمنصبهم بالانتخاب وترقصوا
احزابهم كمان وما خلصوا من هذا الموضوع
خلونا نتكلم اكثر مع ضيفنا من القاهره
الدكتور سعيد صادق استاذ علم الاجتماع
السياسي اهلا فيك معنا دكتور سعيد يعني
صراحه السؤال اللي طرحته رئيسه وزراء
نيوزيلندا صحيح انه هل لو كانوا هم الرجال
كانوا سالوا هذا السؤال
انا افتكرت هي اسالهم انت جايه من فنلندا
لنيوزيلندا عشان بلاك فرايدي نعمل شوبنج
لفساتين ولا حاجه
مضحكه جدا الشيء المضحك الشيء المضحك اولا
نيوزيلندا اول دوله في العالم
بتسمح بالتصويت للمراه
1893 اول دوله في العالم تسمح بالتصوير
الثانيه في العالم كانت همم في اوروبا او
الاولى في اوروبا كانت في اللاندا
1906 سمحت للمراه بالتصويت وانها تترشح
وكان اول امراه تدخل الامانات في العالم
كانت في فنلندا فطبعا الاثنين دول دولتين
دول نيوزيلندا وفي اللاندا بيتفخوا دائما
انهم كانوا اوائل الدول في العالم في همم
الحقوق اللي تم اعطائها للنساء حتى في كل
التصنيفات الدوليه بنج اللاندا ونيوزيلندا
من الاوائل فطبعا السؤال اللي اتقال دوت
يديك انطباعي يا اما الشخص ده لا هو من
نيوزلندا ولا هو من فنلندا من بلد ثانيه
وبيفتقد انها دي حاجه يعني غريبه الغريب
في الموضوع ايه ان المؤسسات السياسيه لما
طلعت في العالم كانت مؤسسات ذكوريه كان
دائما في تحيز على الرجاله الدستور
الامريكي اللي اتعمل
1,789 كان لم يذكر ان المراه له حقت تصوت
ولا تنزل في في اي انتخابات ولا حاجه
ونضله الامريكيه لحد ما اخذت حقا انها
تنزل تترشح
1920 والاول مره يبقى عندك نائبه دلوقت
يعني انت همم اميك حتى يعني مؤخره بالنسبه
لفلان ده ونيوزيلندا همم بريطانيا في
تاريخها كله اكثر من 10 قرون ما جالهاش
غير ثمان ملكات فطبعا عندنا تحيز في
المؤسسات السياسيه الثقافه السياسيه ضد
المراه
اعتقد دكتور سعيد انه خلص نحنا بارزين في
مجالاتنا وفي كثير من المجالات لمثل مجتمع
هيفضل يتعامل معنا على نظريه انه يعني هذه
جايه هنا بالصدفه معانا هي في الاساس كان
لازم تكون حبيبتي في المطبخ
طبعا
احنا عندنا في العالم حاليا يمكن 26 نقع
ماسكه سلطه تنفيذيه همم لكن اللي بيحصل
طبعا همم الناس لسه مش متعوده في بعض حتى
عن هذه الدول يعني متقدمه وتاريخها طويله
حتى همم في اللاندا مثلا سنه 90 كان عندها
اول وزير الدفاع في العالم باذن الله
احنا صايرين موجودين احنا هنعودهم لازم
نقعد عندكم في البيت يا دكتور سعيد عشان
تقتنعه ههه
واحنا شوفنا كلهم في منتهى الكفاءه يعني
الكفاءه اللي عملتها السيدات احنا اولا
ليه السيدات دخلت في السياسه اصلا هم
دخلوا ليه هم لما لقوا ان الرجاله مش
عارفين يعملوا اداره للميزانيه ولا
السياسات العامه المراه طول الوقت بتشتغل
في التعليم في
تغذيه البيت في الصحه بتاعت البيت فهي
حاسه انها فاهمه اكتر من الرجاله اللي
قاعدين يعملوا قرارات وكلها خاطئه وبتعمل
مشاكل فبتقاد تطلب انها تنزل قال لها لا
ما تنزليش لانك انت امراه ابتدت تناضل
وكان بيتم قتلهم لما كانوا بيطالبه بحقهم
انهم ياخذوا حق التصويت فطبعا المراه
ادخلها مهم جدا للسياحه
بالضبط وكمان لانه المساله مساله كفاءه
يعني بس خليني اقول لك بدي اقرا لك عنوان
الزملاء في صحيفه الشرق الاوسط كل التحيه
لهم بس حاطين عنوان انه رئيستا وزراء
نيوزيلندا وفنلندا تحرجان صحفيا بسبب سؤال
عن سنهما فهم شايفين ان هم اللي احرجوا
الصحفي تعتقد اللي كتب العنوان هذا رجل
همم لا اعتقد او ممكن حد مؤمن
بالنساويه بالمساواه فممكن يكون رجل
مستنيايا او ممكن
الصحفي وكانه مش الصحفي كانت غلطته
انه جاهل بتاريخ نيوزيلندا وتاريخ في
فنلندا لانه لو كان درس التاريخ هيعرف ان
دول اوائل الدول في العالم في الموضوع حق
التصويت وحق الترشيح في الانتخابات
مهمه في العمليه السياسيه
علم الاجتماع السياسي شكرا لك
نهايه السنه بدات المنصات والتطبيقات
والشركات كلها تنزل احصائياتها وتقاريرها
الثانويه في عالم الموسيقى سبوتيفاي راب
تحدث بيستناه مستخدمين تطبيق من السنه وفي
الشركه بتعرض لكل مستخدم تقرير مفصل لك عن
ايش سمع المفضل وهكذا والناس
وكان نتيجه
من التعليقات والنكت من المستخدمين عرب
واجانب على الموضوع
لكن زي ما كل مستخدم له سبوتفاير رابط
كمان سبوتيفاي بتعمل
الاستماع على التطبيق كله وفي تفاعلكم
زودونا باحصائيات عن الفنانين والاغاني
الاكثر استماعا خلونا نستعرضها سوا وخلونا
نبدا في الشرق الاوسط هذه هي اكثر اغاني
سماعات واكثر فنانين عرب كمان
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
اما في السعوديه فاللي هتشوفوهم الان وما
اكثر الفنانين السعوديين اجتماعا على
سبسكرايب في 20 22
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
ومع نهايه السنه بدات المنصات والتطبيقات
والشركات كلها تنزل احصائياتها وتقاريرها
السنويه وفي عالم الموسيقى سبوتيفاي راب
تحدث بيستناه مستخدمي التطبيق من السنه
وفي الشركه بتعرض لكل مستخدم تقرير مفصل
لك عن ايش
سمعوا المفضل وهكذا والناس قبل بتتحمس على
النزوله وكان نتيجه امتحان ولما بنزل كمان
بيعلقوا بيضحكوا عليه ومن وقت ما نزل
الاسبوع الفايبر
العالم وهي عينه من التعليقات والنكت من
المستخدمين عرب واجانب على الموضوع
لكن زي ما كل مستخدم له اسبوع كمان
الاستماع على التطبيق ككل وفي تفاعلكم
زودونا باحصائيات عن الفنانين والاغاني
الاكثر استماعا خلونا نستعرضها سوا وخلونا
نبدا في الشرق الاوسط هذه هي اكثر اغاني
سماعات واكثر فنانين عرب كمان
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
اما في السعوديه فلا هتشوفوهم الان هما
اكثر الفنانين السعوديين اجتماعا على 20
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]